[Music]
so coming off a prison break in the last
season
and we'll see how this goes because this
is actually not a story that i've ever
told publicly before but
we were sitting around one day we were
shooting the scene
and there was this um
porn video that was going around called
two chicks one cup
that i've never seen
but we were sitting around a table
and the guys started texting it to each
other and watching it
and laughing
i don't give a [ __ ] you know what i mean
like do whatever you want to do we
weren't shooting we were setting up a
shot
and then they started saying
oh callies that looks like you that's
you
and they went on this whole like it was
a fascinating dynamic in retrospect
because every one of them individually
almost 201 was a friend
but they became a wolf pack
like
immediately and i'm looking around i'm
the only girl right like this was
wow what 2008 yeah yeah it would have
been 2008 um because i just had the baby
and
and i was like no seriously knock it off
i don't like being called a shit-eating
[ __ ]
um
and they doubled down
and one of the people at that table at
the time was a very very close friend
and i was looking over going
he's got the most power of anybody in
this room all he's got to do is say
hey leave her alone yeah that's all it
would have taken like no grandstanding
no fist fights no nothing just [ __ ]
leave her alone
nothing and i got to a point where i was
like
well i'm not gonna cry
so
i'm not gonna say anything
and i mean producers directors first ads
all standing around all seeing this all
hearing this
and i was like hmm
it was a moment and this happens
as a woman walking through the world
when all of a sudden you're like
oh i'm way more vulnerable than i
realized i was
and just emotionally like no you know
what's gonna hurt me
but my [ __ ] feelings were hurt you
know what i mean i was like oh i thought
we were friends
but if you can sit here and
call me a [ __ ] even more
over my objections
in the workplace
maybe i've
misjudged this situation
i went home
and
i told my husband
and then spent the next hour
dealing with you know i was like i need
you to call i need this to be about me
right now i need this not to be but like
i'm going to move in someone's ass i
respect the fact that as a man you want
to go handle this but a that makes my
life more complicated and b like i
really just need to fall apart right now
how many times do you think you've gone
home and josh i'm like i'm going to [ __ ]
somebody up at your job like like like
like what do you well part of the thing
about walking dead was never on that
show right and so part of like to bring
this back to your question the person
that you were to me
was somebody who was
who shared my definition of loyalty and
i've come to understand as an adult and
especially in this business my
definition of loyalty is like
[ __ ] medieval do you know what i mean
it's straight up lancelot night of the
round table
that means something to me
um
and
it doesn't mean that to everybody and
i've learned to like let that go and be
like hey you get to that's fine i think
that's life or do you think that's his
business i think it's got to be both
um
but i definitely think that there are
people who have gotten into this
business because they lacked the courage
to do other things
not to say that this business is easy
right but
i think sometimes
maybe particularly men
who
aspire to certain aspects of masculinity
and so they put them on rather than
actually learning them from the inside
out
not always
certainly but
what i found in you
and in andy
was like no when we say we got you
we mean we're gonna start by creating a
culture where that's not gonna happen we
never talked about it but like
there was a level of safety on that set
and a level of mutual respect
and like it's funny because
you know
certain people who know me would think
of me as strong or ferocious
but very little matters more to me than
just feeling
safe
and
it's kind of staggering how often as a
woman in the world
the
um we're just so often just
not safe you know either because there's
some producer who's saying something or
some director with his hands all over
you or you know you got to walk around
like wolverine with your keys through
your fingers at night like
i think those things are connected that
i did the best work of my life
partly because
in a weird way you and andy set up a
perimeter and we're like nothing's
coming for you in here so we can take
big risks
because
nothing's coming for you in here and if
they do they're coming through us and
we've got this
and the funny thing is what that brings
out in me is like cool i got you too you
know what i mean i was gonna say i will
create this situation you know i will
make this safe for you in different ways
i'm not gonna like fight somebody to
death but you know i'm gonna emotionally
make sure that like there are boundaries
and that when you say things to me that
are vulnerable i hold them and i keep
them and i keep them safe yeah um
that i think is where
it's something that i've learned as a
director that like you have to create
this deeply safe environment for people
to do dangerous work
you can't do
dangerous work if you don't feel safe
what do you think about that like what
do you think about like the state of
things
now
it's tricky i mean look i was i've been
on set doing a love scene with a
director calling while we're rolling
just take your shirt off
what like i don't have a nudity rider
just say just it's not a big deal i
won't show it just take your shirt off
like
what am i supposed to do it's the
beginning of my career this guy's a big
deal like
you know so like definitely an intimacy
coordinator in that moment to go
what the [ __ ] yeah cut the camera she's
not gonna take a shirt i'm like dude i
mean like
yes
but in theory
man it's tough because in theory those
those protocols are there for
when there needs to be an intercession
between the relationship between the
actors
but there's so much
panic and fear on the part of
productions and
understandably but
i think there are times where it feels
like
they're doing this [ __ ] because they
think they should
not because they genuinely care totally
and
real dumb move of me to think that like
the studios care
right that's not that's they would
probably say it's not my job my job is
to make a show right like covering your
ass and caring are two totally different
things a thousand percent yeah um and i
don't know if anybody ever cared like
did louis b mayer ever care right you
know like i think it's possible that
that kind of nurturing environment
is more of a fantasy in our heads of
you know
whatever of what theater was to us when
we were young or whatever but i think
there's also there's like safety can
only be created by but but by people who
are willing to lay down for each other
like that's what safety is like safety
is not about right covering your ass or
like it can't be about words it has to
be willingness to take action that that
feeling is kind of always there right
like like like how replaceable you are
and it's cultivated yeah it's absolutely
cultivated and it's purposeful right
like that's what you mean by cultivating
yeah yeah yeah i mean but also you know
i mean look in a lot of ways it's also
true do you what i mean like if i step
away from a job there's gonna be a
hundred five eight brunettes right who
step up and go i'll do it you know and
like i'm aware of that when i negotiate
when i like
walk away from a job because the studio
is not willing to offer me parody with
the man who has the equivalent
you know salary right like
the response is always we'll find
somebody else who will do it i'm like
you're right you will
but
i don't know that i can look my kids in
the eye and be like mama's going to work
for 40 cents on the dollar see you kids
i just don't know that i can do that
and
but they you know they know when they
know that especially women the more
likely they are to take a lower salary
because there's less opportunity
you know and i
i think at a certain point
it becomes about like do you want to do
this anymore
you know like do you want to be an actor
anymore i like kind of leaning into
certain kinds of directing because like
you know the dga says this is what you
get for an episode they don't negotiate
differently with men than they do with
women is what you get it's on a schedule
it's less money
but it's equal money i mean i took a
huge pay cut to do walking dead but i
did it because the four of us had parody
and i was like
this isn't about money to me
this is about
are we doing the same job for the same
respect because you and i are both the
breadwinners of our family
my kids don't deserve less
just because i happen to be a girl
that's right right and so
i think fundamentally
the only thing that i've really been
able to come to
is like we
have to come up with like a deep
rehabilitative forgiveness in this
culture
it starts with asking for it
it starts with what does it mean for a
man to go
i did not think that the thing i did
would hurt you oh because here's an
interesting ps that whole thing that
happened on prison break
then we go back and we do season five
like seven years later
i'm sitting at a table with one of these
guys
and i was like i just got to tell you
that [ __ ] me up for a minute
and he goes what did
and what became obvious was that day had
no significance to him
it was in my head for a long time right
conversations with like my attorney
going hey listen if you go public with
this fox will make sure you never work
again
like
my career
it happened to me and my career ended up
on the line by the end of the phone call
and like never sometimes that happened
would you say in your career that like
people were like don't either either it
came from you or an external source
where people where it was just like dude
if i say something here i'm [ __ ] oh oh
yeah i'm countless right
way more than i could count way more
than i could count
because also then there's a like it's
your word against mine dude i mean and
like all i've got to do is when they
call me to say
should i hire her go she's difficult
that's all that's that's it job's over
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's jon
bam bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team i just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that i bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something i'm i'm just super
proud of and again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further we're
going to introduce a patreon community
and basically what that means is if you
become part of this community look i
already board bam bam if you want to
become a part of this community you're
going to be able to hear episodes early
and all that ad free and all that good
stuff but there's all this behind the
scenes footage all this stuff that we've
shot
that really brings you into the folks
that we've had on the show really brings
you into their world you're going to be
able to do live chats with me and the
folks that i bring on the show to talk
about their world talk about the issues
that they're dealing with about their
triumphs and their tragedies just go to
patreon
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
was um something about building bridges
and and bringing people together and
bringing folks that often don't get the
mic and giving the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tune in means the
world anyways again thank you be good to
each other out there rock and roll